[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vivre avec un nouveau visage
comment ça se passe non hélas monde du
white c'est pas mal bossé huile visage
là y'a jamais pensé à son ancien visage
ou le visage cave à vin l'huile son
visage lokéo là et ils chient premier
match trouve beau c'est vrai qu'ils
aient baudoux puis le monde disait pour
l'action c'est comme ça et je sais mieux
sourit quand je vois maurès suis relax
c'est quand je suis pas avec marc et
sénat que j'étais plus stressée mais
quoi c'était grosse année beaucoup de
défis beaucoup défi ouais beaucoup de
stress mais ce ça va bien
est ce qu'une chance qu'elle était la
[Musique]
chanson la chanson une chance concept on
s'attendait à une évolution comme on l'a
eu évidemment l'arrêt mais quelque chose
de parfait mais on n'a pas été surpris
du déroulement de l'année
on était prêt à ça le pire a été évité
le système immunitaire de maurice
desjardins n'a pas rejeté son nouveau
visage
mais cette victoire a un prix à cause
des médicaments anti-rejets l'homme
reste vulnérable à la moindre infection
donc on eu qu'à être le problème
infectieux en courant d'animer des
problèmes infectieux qui ont été faciles
à identifier qui ont bien répondu au
traitement par la suite c'est embêtant
pour lui sa famille par contre parce que
ça nécessite une hospitalisation qui
s'est jamais agréable mais ces
infections là on ne put les traiter
adéquatement le reste tu fais pas je le
vois était ouvert à 3 mm le temps c'est
de santé m pourquoi vous avez cessez vos
exercices un échec c'était pourquoi
maintenant il ne peut plus fermer la
bouche et en jambes ankylosées dans les
articulations qui s'installe et quand tu
bouges peuvent contient une plante sur
une bras et tu n'utilises pas pendant un
mois c'est très difficile à dire raid
même chose fait qu' il n'y ait pas
qu'ils aient la gauche pendant plusieurs
mois
alors ça reste dans cette position là où
la bougie
tu sais je peux pas le blâmer parce qu'a
eu d autres complications il ya
d'infection ici l'outil infections là et
chaque fois qu'il ya entre une infection
il vient ici pour le traitement c'est
difficile de prendre un rôle d'homme de
réadaptation au total trois infections
majeurs ont nécessité dix semaines
d'hospitalisation et tout cela a culminé
en mars dernier il a eu une infection au
niveau du tube digestif qu'on appelle
une diverticulite et malheureusement
l'intestin une petite pochette
s'infecter que ces ruptures et à ce
moment là je peux avoir une chirurgie
pour enlever le bout d'intestin qui
était malade et onu m pendant que ça
guérit une colostomie donc une poche
pour évacuer les selles septans portr en
attendant que l'intestin donc guérissent
et dans quelques mois les charges et
vont pouvoir aller enlever cette poche
le maurice prend une quinzaine de
médicaments par jour et lui sont
injectés par la sonde qui sert à le
gaver c'est que ces problèmes c'est que
tout le temps peur de tromper parce que
tellement de sortes de médicaments
c'est comme tu veux pas tu veux pas
donner un médicament qui poster loppsi
faux choix et ben bella thaçi qu'est ce
que je fais parce que c'est quand même
une job à 20 80 kg est vraiment et vous
avez donc même cessé de travailler je
pense pour s'occuper des choix cette
perte d'emploi à trajet lisez leur
situation financière
et puis chaque semaine depuis un an
guettant effectué plusieurs allers
retours entre le centre de réadaptation
résidence et l'hôpital il ya juste
certains centres au québec qui font des
greffes
mais qui parle du monde reste pas à côté
de leur centre pour faire des suivis
votre médecin
avec les intérêts propres et
d'adaptation tout ce qui vient avec
mais il faut quitter votre maison ça
coûte cher de prendre votre note hall
s'est pas couvert nécessairement
stationnés plusieurs médicaments qui
sont pas couverts alors c'est ça coûte
cher
et malgré tout ça est ce que vous
regrettez votre décision
non ça vaut toujours la peine guey déjà
vous pour la peine ça vous la jouer
[Musique]